alguém aqui usa algum tipo de droga
optimus corajosos alguém está neste
momento com algum tipo de droga mas
corajosa assustador também eu também tô
bem assustado aqui antes de iniciar a
minha fala eu gostaria de agradecer essa
oportunidade de falar sobre o assunto
tão importante que é o slow pharmacy a
gente tem essa incrível mania de
utilizar o medicamento como remédio e
pensar somente dessa forma ea gente não
vê o medicamento como droga
a gente não pára pra pensar nisso e
precisa parar pra pensar dá pra pensar
em movimento e é isso que é o slow
pharma assim é um movimento que visa a
reflexão sobre o uso exacerbado de
medicamentos
prestem atenção eu não estou falando pra
deixar de tomar medicamentos de uso
controlado
eu trouxe um gráfico que mostra a adesão
mundial ao movimento sou pharmacy
segundo pesquisa científica 10% da
população mundial já aderiu ao movimento
impressionante não não eu inventei esse
dado
sou eu
por enquanto eu espero que até o fim da
palestra sejamos nós a ok
somos todos os usuários de drogas
então é preciso aceitar o slow pharmacy
no nosso coração
para isso nós temos três passos
essenciais
o primeiro passo é assumir o vício
tivemos aqui corajosos que assumir o
vício
ah mas eu eu só tomo um comprimidinho de
vez em quando
ai como eu vou parar de tomar
medicamento cara eles colocam cantor
sertanejo ator/atriz pagodeiro
chicleteiro coloca uma galera pra fazer
propaganda de medicamentos como eu
resisto
como falo não não eu vou resistir às
tentações
é difícil a gente deve abandonar os
comprimidos de bolso
sabe aquele comprimido que você deixa na
bolsa pra mim e se eu tiver uma dor de
cabeça
e se eu tiver uma cólica esse e sim é a
personificação do medo eo medo é a maior
ferramenta de controle
hoje em dia enquanto você tem medo de
controlo oc
eu não quero mais ter medo então a gente
vai para o nosso segundo passo a
reabilitação
a gente tenta restabelecer a nossa
autonomia e o nosso auto controle é um
momento meio de reflexão da vida pra
onde vamos de onde viemos quem somos
para onde minha vida tá indo mas é uma
montanha
fria o tática gigante é uma barreira ou
é uma barra e você tem que atravessar da
montanha
você tem que ser ventura você tem que se
abrir para esse novo caminho é um
caminho de cura pra isso
nós temos quatro princípios fundamentais
da nossa reabilitação
já vejo risadas psicoterapia a
psicoterapia é mais usual na sua forma
individual e na sua forma em grupo mas
tem uma ramificação que a boteco terapia
ninguém sabe do que eu estou falando né
ok os botecos tenham a instigante
intelectual que promove discussões
saudáveis onde você consegue perceber
que você não é um allen que você não
está sozinho e falar quem é tão pessoal
a luta que nem eu que da hora
vamos junto então pelo menos é uma
duplinha a gente também tenho mais
recomendado pelos médicos
a boa alimentação e exercícios físicos
exercícios físicos o que eles não falam
é que eles ativam muito a nossa glândula
timo e isso provoca uma descarga
hormonal que traz um sentimento de
sermos imbatíveis e aí não tem pra
ninguém
se alguém chega numa conversa sem
aquecer aqui é slow farmácias irmão já
bate no peito já tive ótimo ou seja tá
no movimento
estamos também é uma boa terapia o nosso
terceiro princípio que traz a
responsabilidade hamas na culpa minha se
tem o marketing farmacêutico
tudo será eternamente responsável pela
droga que cativas em seu organismo
já dizia um sábio
caso nenhum desses três princípios
funcione
nós vamos para a internação mas não é
com o uso de drogas é uma internação de
imersão então você vai atrás de pesquisa
você vai atrás de dado científico
você vai atrás de mais conhecimento você
volta pra história e tenta entender por
que nós chegamos até aqui antigamente
acreditavam se nós flores vêm sendo
canhões hoje pra nossa cura é preciso
acreditar nas ervas vencendo bilhões
bilhões estes de uma indústria que gera
lucro em cima da tua doença que vive
fazendo dinheiro na manutenção do teu
vício porque curar os nossos vícios não
dá dinheiro
essa é a nossa cura voltar pra raízes
voltar para as nossas origens ouvir os
nossos avós
as grandes matriarcas da nossa família
os grandes mestres populares é conectar
é valorizar a questão indígena a nossa
terra é valorizar a questão africana a
nossa raiz a mais
eu não sei se é realmente isso que eu
quero eu acredito mais na ciência tudo
bem temos 218 anos de farmácia como
ciência
quando você diz isso você também se
questiona a quanto tempo existem os
saberes ancestrais 5718 anos desde o
primeiro registro do uso de uma planta e
o que a gente faz
chega uma benzedeira weverton rai
0o fitomassa que essa plantinha vai
melhorar doador
quem falou
onde você viu isso é formado em que seja
doutor filha seja o teu pai se já deu
pra tua mãe seja teve essa doença
tudo bem é preciso sim questionar é
importantíssimo questionar mas questione
com a mesma igualdade intensidade as
pesquisas científicas porque quando você
lê um artigo
nossa menina civil que o café é bom para
curar a depressão nossa sentiu que esse
negócio de intolerância à lactose e
glúten é tudo frescura nossa
se você não comer carne você vai ficar
muito fraquinho eu vi o villa da revista
a gente tem que refletir sobre isso
entendem a urgência dessa cura a
necessidade da gente trilhar esse
caminho de atravessar essa montanha e
para deixar mais ilustrativo eu vou
pedir licença para a leitura de um poema
de minha autoria
bem vindos à farmácia ciência de cura
que só quer o seu bem
amém mas se for mais além
o conhecimento é mesmo de quem resume 5
mil anos de medicina ancestral em
espantar demônios do corpo ou algo
sobrenatural natural mesmo
são 200 anos de uma ciência de erros que
pensa que o método científico é lei que
nos sustenta o que sustenta mesmo é
arroz com feijão e o nome diz queridos é
apropriação
voltaram seus olhos pra tubos de ensaio
e não consegui enxergar quem está do seu
lado
ignora funcionária que sofre de
depressão
o menino que chora no meio da sala de
aula sem solução ea cada ano que passa é
um lugar a mais vazio
quem são essas pessoas que desistem
isso ninguém viu ou não quer ver usam a
desculpa de que o sistema é mesmo
capitalista se lencinhos ativistas
mas pra cada voz que resiste em falar
uma multidão do lado de fora se faça
escutar e se questione agora onde é que
você está dentro ou fora é um privilégio
poder estudar
então levanta sacode a poeira dá a volta
por cima a mas isso só vai mudar daqui a
100 anos
é papo de quem não está no clima
a mudança já está acontecendo na dúvida
vá pesquisar e se vier me falar
a mesa quer uma diploma e veja bem o teu
conceito atua a ética ea tua honra
porque a universidade é pública e
sustentada pelo povo
resista eu insisto de novo de novo e de
novo ea boa notícia
esse processo não será mais silencioso
no dia a dia é uma batalha entrar aqui
sorrir e dizer bom dia
quando me perguntam ainda quem é o chefe
da minha família que pressionam de
reprimem te colocam no chão toda teoria
linda mas é fia distante sem emoção
e pra nós mulheres a carga ainda mais
bruta e de muita dor quando te obrigam a
estudar com o professor abusador e eu me
pergunto diariamente o que eu faço aqui
então falar porque não está sentado
nesta cadeira
essa é a minha missão e se palavras
ainda não conseguem abrir a sua mente eu
peço um pouco mais de atenção esteja
presente em uma indústria de cura e bem
estar da população
como existem tantas mentes doentes e sem
coração para seguir em frente
progredir é preciso estar junto servir
acolher cuidar empatia é não deixar sua
fé no mundo se abalar
obrigada
[Aplausos]